it's time for hatred mail a lot of focus
a lot of reaction to my segment last
week
am i hispanic am i latino am I just a
white guy and this week's hatred focuses
on that but first a quick reminder what
is hatred mail anyway because if you
aren't pro-life you deserve the death
penalty patriot mail written by Patriots
who hate David Pakman because America
and because freedom like with many weeks
this week's hatred mail needs no more
introduction than to say that a lot of
people beyond me saying that a lot of
people were extremely triggered by
learning that yes I am an immigrant to
the United States from Latin America
take a listen to this David you are a
Hispanic Latinos just accepted yet
another great reason why you should
never have been allowed in I know you
want to be white but sadly for you no no
no you can speak Spanish as much as you
want but no can do here you will never
be American I am Hispanic Latinos and
speaking Spanish is something that we
really need to be looking into very very
much more I I don't really have much
more to say about it I think it really
speaks for itself the only thing I will
remind you of is that the best way to
height to fight hate reott ISM in your
own community is to use the coupon code
hey tree at 40 when you become a member
on our website join pakman.com the
coupon code hey tree at 40 saves you 40%
you get 100% of the member benefits and
it's a big double middle finger to the
hey tree 'it's which we just love and
and encourage so please sign up at join
pakman.com apply the coupon code hey
tree at 40 do the right thing a fight
hate reott ism in your local community